wann können wir die musik stattfinden
weil ich vermisse es sehr auf der bühne
zu stehen und würde es eigentlich auch
noch dieses jahr personal so werden
dieses jahr noch die musik stattfinden
und wann können wir eigentlich wieder
ins training gehen
also ich würde mal sagen weil du sagst
die gefahr dass musicals dieses jahr mit
stattfinden ich bin sicher in diesem
jahr wird so was wieder stattfinden wann
kann ich nicht hundertprozentig
versprechen wir werden jetzt genau
schauen entscheiden wenn die zahlen
weiter niedrig sind und wir kluge
konzepte haben also mit mehr
schnelltests mit entsprechenden auch
abständen dann glaube ich lässt sich da
manches organisieren eins nach dem
anderen wenn die zahl niedrig sind wird
es sicherlich so gehen das gleiche gilt
für den ganzen sport bereich man wird
allerdings bei sport er mit den dingen
anfangen die weniger körperkontakt haben
judo noch nach meiner erfahrung hat
ziemlichen körperkontakt also man wird
jetzt eher was anfangen was bisschen
weiter entfernt ist wie die bi tennis
beispielsweise da hört man durch einen
anderen abstand oder andere einzelne
sportarten judo glaube ich könnte noch
nicht als erstes dran sein
wir müssen einfach das geschehen
beobachten aber wisst ihr das eigentlich
entscheide ist wenn es uns gelingt
möglichst weiter so viel zu impfen und
noch viel mehr zu impfen
dann wird es sowieso leichter und ich
wünsche mir übrigens sehr dass wir auch
bald ein impfstoff für kinder haben
größte wunsch werde noch zusätzlichen
impfstoff für kinder und jugendliche zu
haben denn wenn wir das hätten dann sind
die ganzen beschränkungen für euch fast
weg deswegen auch noch mal mein appell
nun müssen wir machen die
impfstoffhersteller nicht nur für die
älteren zu impfen es ist wichtig weil
dort ist die todesrate leider sehr hoch
sondern auch für euch an impfstoff zu
haben und dann könnte man in der schule
alle durch impfen und dann hätte man
nach wenigen wochen wieder absolute
freiheit das wäre glaube ich der
langfristige weg der funktioniert ich
bin da wollte ich sie fragen wann die
eigentlich wieder sehen können
du bist das obermichelbach im landkreis
fürth studios
also in der unmittelbaren am berg ja
also sofern noch mal größe von fränk
hinzu frank her wir haben es echt
schützen müssen die schützen müssen und
opa und oma sind diejenigen die wenn sie
eine erkrankung wie corona bekommen mit
schlimmen folgen haben wenn es jetzt
jemand jugendlicher ist zum beispiel
dann ist kann auch was passieren aber
die folgen sind nicht so gefährlich
bei oma und opa können sie sehr
gefährlich sein so jetzt ist so dass die
zahlen insgesamt verbessert sind auch
gerade bei uns in der region sind sie
besser geworden und das impfen hilft ich
weiß nicht ob es oma und opa dir schon
geimpft sind aber in dem zeitpunkt wo
sie geimpft sind und sie warten da
glaube ich auch drauf im impfzentrum
dann ist es natürlich deutlich besser
dann gibt es viel mehr möglichkeiten die
kontakte zu haben also noch ein bisschen
durchhalten und ich nehme an ihr habt ja
auch ein bisschen entweder will scribd
oder telefoniert oder wurde euch zu
geben und ähnliches mehr
wir hatten ja alle weihnachten diese
große herausforderung danke auch wie das
alles gemeistert hat und glaubt mir
oma opa wollen die mindestens so sehr
sehen und haben sich mindestens so lieb
wie umgekehrt
und wenn sie geimpft sind dann kann man
durchschlafen sich besser sind aber es
ist ja eine ganze liste die drucken
möchte ist also in die schule das müsste
jetzt ja klappen beim urlaub also ich
würde nicht so weit gehen wie man
freunde michael kretschmer der gesagt
dann osterurlaub gibt's auf keinen fall
ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht bis
ostern ist noch eine zeit hin
vielleicht ist die lage besser
wir haben den letzten drei vier wochen
deutlicher verbesserung erlebt sie sich
wegen solcher beleg dafür dass alles was
wir gemacht haben richtig war weil die
zahlen runter gegangen sind
es war im dezember war die lage recht
düster in einigen städten sogar
zappenduster
und das ist jetzt wieder sehr hell nicht
nur die sonne draußen sondern
tatsächlich aber wir müssen jetzt die
mutation erwarten wenn es dann besser
wird dann gibt es sicherlich auch
möglichkeiten in deutschland zu
überlegen ob so was sinnvoll ist oder
nicht aber das kann man aus heutiger
sicht noch nicht abschätzen
da würde ich kein versprechen abgeben
wollen aber schule wird besser werden
kleine dinge wie zum beispiels weise ist
dann wo die zahl niedrig sind denkbar
aber für den urlaub
im laufe des jahres hoffentlich bestimmt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren